es reicht wir wollen unser normales
leben zurück das fordert bild diese
woche das ende der korona maßnahmen
abgesehen von der masken pflicht wie in
unseren nachbarländern zum beispiel und
zwar am besten soll das ganze passieren
bei uns in der woche der liebe der woche
des valentintags wann ist der vierzehnte
februar genau könnte keine bessere geben
für die freedom weg aus liebe zur
freiheit so zu sagen
es reicht gibt uns unser normales leben
zurück fordert bild und millionen
deutsche sagen so ist es kommt langsam
zur vernunft seht euch die zahlen an vor
allem versucht uns nicht zu veräppeln
regel regeln runterfahren einfach
abschaffen stück für stück an an denen
hat orientieren schon was dänemark
gemacht hat die wie sich orientiert
haben zahlen runter maßnahmen runter und
nicht immer noch verschärfen nicht die
2g plus regelung das ist umständlich und
das hilft niemanden schafft eine
maßnahme ab ich glaube gefährlicher als
bild haben die hmi ist mittlerweile dass
die leute durch sind und brauchen wir
ihre freiheit es macht keinen sinn den
fussball stadions hat 10.000 zuschauer
zu spielen die an öffentlichen mit einem
ass crm zu laufen oder hier eine straße
bringt menschen sehr oft fahren die mit
masken vista sinnlos ist
mit dem osten gute aufträge denn längst
ist klar die lage auf den
intensivstationen ist stabil omikron ist
harmloser als gedacht die maßnahmen
wirken kaum dagegen und auch fast alle
anderen länder um uns herum machen auf
bild leib chef claus strunz fordert wenn
ich richtig sie beginnt die woche mit
dem valentinstag also einem großen tag
der liebe dann lasst uns doch die
nächste woche zur freiheits woche machen
in deutschland und damit ist er nicht
allein nach diesem wirklich zwei oder
zweieinhalb sehr intensiv und
anstrengenden jahren für uns alle wird
es einfach zeit dass wir endlich diese
maske ablegen dürfen uns nicht ständig
wieder gedanken machen müssen muss ich
mich noch testen wo darf ich hin was
muss ich beachten es wird zeit und ich
freue mich auf diese aufbruchstimmung
und auch die positivität und dass wir
endlich wieder alle zusammen spaß haben
dürfen irgendwann muss es doch mal gut
sein wir müssen nach vorne gehen und
dann einfach mal sagen jetzt leben wir
wieder normal so wie es einfach früher
war
dänemark macht den anfang vielleicht
zieht deutschland hinterher wer weiß ich
würde es mir wünschen ja wir wollen
unser normales leben zurück das sagt
auch brautmode unternehmerin sonja
katharina handke aus köln vor corinna
hatte ich sechzehn heute noch fünf
mitarbeiterinnen die regeln müssen weg
damit die brautpaare wieder sicher ihre
hochzeiten planen können bei uns hat
eine braut 100 quadratmeter platz muss
trotzdem maske tragen und im restaurant
sitzen alle dicht an dicht und
fitnessstudiobetreiber harry chaos das
auf unserem rücken die korona regeln
ausgetragen werden ist ungerecht die
kunden sind zu bequem sich für einen
besuch testen zu lassen
gleich anfang des jahres sind uns über
200 verträge weggebrochen ich musste
schon an meine renten rücklagen rand um
miete und krankenkasse zu bezahlen und
automatenaufsteller thorsten japs aus
damon aus die hotels in dem meine snack
und getränkeautomaten stehen haben durch
fehlenden tourismus kaum umsatz bisher
überlebte ich mit krediten und corona
hilfen wegen der rückzahlungsforderung
eines großteils der hilfen überlege ich
aufzugeben und millionen weitere
lassen wir hier menschen zu wort kommen
die genau dasselbe fordern uns
zugeschaltet ist jetzt
cdu-bundestagsabgeordnete jana schimke
frosch imke und ebenfalls der ex formel
1 moderator und reisejournalist kai
böcking kai böcking und last but not und
sprechen wir mit dem unternehmer stephan
frenkel franken 74 exklusive bowling
lounges in vier verschiedenen
bundesländern das heißt sie mussten das
volle corona maßnahmen würde ertragen
vielleicht die erste frage direkt an sie
wie sehr wünschen sie sich den freedom
day ja also mehr als alles andere es ist
tatsächlich so dass wir in vier
bundesländern sind und auch vier
verschiedene verordnungen haben und das
ist für unser geschäft natürlich ein
wahnsinn wir haben über 100000 euro für
hygiene maßnahmen ausgegeben und ja es
wird zeit dass wir unser normales leben
zurückbekommen und
ein beispiel in hannover am letzten
wochenende hatten wir von
freitag bis sonntag 4 150 anrufe für
reservierungen weil
online nichts mehr zu verlieren war und
wir leider in niedersachsen jeder zweite
bahn verkaufen und vermieten dürfen und
ja das sind wahnsinnige einbußen die wir
haben und wir brauchen unsere freiheit
zurück und ich bin leider unsere
nachbarn in dänemark wo ich auch gute
geschäftskontakte hin habe und ja es
muss jetzt wieder was passieren und wir
brauchen
weiter zurück und unsere gäste und
unsere haben sehnen sich danach
rücke das sind die ganz persönliche
gründe auch geschäftliche gründe die sie
haben ich spreche mit frau schimke sie
ist politikerin
cdu-bundestagsabgeordnete sie muss also
abwägen über den dingen stehen es gibt
ja pro und contra stimmen warum sagen
auch sie herr mit der freedom week na ja
weil ich einfach nah bei den menschen
bin und weil ich sehe was in diesem land
los ist ja und ich frage mich ganz
ehrlich was musste noch geschehen damit
wir endlich unser leben zurückbekommen
wir wissen die intensivstationen sind
nicht überlastet wir wissen omikron ist
nicht mehr so gefährlich wir wissen aber
sehr wohl dass die kollateralschäden in
der wirtschaft bei kindern und
jugendlichen erheblich sind und ich sage
ihnen politik ist auch nur so gut wie
sie von den menschen akzeptiert und
gelebt wird und was wir im moment
erleben sind entscheidungen sind
politische entscheidungen die die die
mit dem lebensgefühl der menschen mit
der lebensrealität der menschen nicht
mehr viel zu tun haben dieses land ist
einfach was das emotionale angeht
ziemlich am ende und deswegen glaube ich
müssen wir dringend jetzt auch abrüsten
bei den maßnahmen und zur normalität
zurückkehren herr böcking was sind denn
ihre ganz persönlichen gründe die
freedom weg nächste woche endlich
einzuläuten
ja ich glaube einfach dass wir aufhören
müssen allen menschen so viel angst zu
machen ich bin trotz kroner in den
letzten jahren 200 tage im jahr
unterwegs gewesen auf der ganzen welt
und ich habe einfach festgestellt klar
wir haben alle dieses problem mit dem
virus und die pandemie ist überall aber
es gibt einfach länder wo man sehr viel
entspannter damit umgeht und da geht es
gar nicht darum dass man da keine maske
tragen muss bleibt dass man ein raise
noch ein test vorlegen muss und es geht
darum dass die menschen einfach nicht so
viel angst haben sie in den bereichen wo
sie sich bewegen dürfen auch frei
bewegen und ich habe immer das gefühl
ich lieber in bayern dass man immer wenn
ich zurückkomme von der reise ist wieder
neue regeln gibt die kein mensch
verstehen die sich ändern wäre es gerade
wieder heute morgen erlebt bei uns
ändert sich hier in bayern jetzt wieder
alles ist es wieder zwei geld
abgeschafft es kommt 3g nur da in diesen
bereichen und für mich ist es einfach so
ich habe die erfahrung gemacht in denen
in den letzten monaten dass man einfach
aufhören muss den menschen immer angst
zu machen es ist so wie es ist und wir
wissen alle das ist keine gute zeit war
aber es muss jetzt wirklich mal schluss
sein die menschen immer noch mehr angst
zu machen drei stimmen die für immer
mehr menschen in diesem land sprechen
die sagen es reicht gebt uns unser
normales leben zurück sowie bild das
fordert vielen dank für ihre meinung
dankeschön